ice cream for inoculations russia's
authorities say they've been doing what
they can to encourage people to get the
covet shot for almost a year
but only about one-third of russians are
fully vaccinated
reservations remain about the sputnik
v-jab and the government's push for it
they shouldn't force us
they should try to motivate us
with a low vaccination rate and
currently around 40 000 infections per
day it could be a bleak winter ahead
welcome to your covenant 19 special i'm
chris colbert in berlin moscow is back
under its tightest lockdown restrictions
in over a year
after daily covet 19 deaths hit another
new record of more than 1100 recently
now non-essential services will stay
closed until the end of the week despite
the surge in cases the majority of
russians have yet to heed urgent calls
to get vaccinated
a new day a new tragic record as the
highly infectious delta variant
continues to spread
russia's covet wards continue to fill
primarily with the unvaccinated
images of patients infected with the
coronavirus have become a fixture on
russian news programs but they have done
little to convince a skeptical
population to get vaccinated
forcing the authority's hand
moscow's mayor joined other regional
leaders declaring an 11 day soft
lockdown for the capital closing bars
cafes theaters and other public spaces
it coincides with a federal week-long
work holiday and stay-at-home orders for
the elderly and vulnerable authorities
hope the short fire break will help them
weather the pandemic's fourth wave
health experts welcome the announcement
but warn it's too little too late
[Music]
11 days isn't enough at all
it's another example of a half measure
and an attempt to please everyone
but you have to keep public health in
mind
in the current situation we can't use
abstractions we're talking about real
deaths real illness and long covid we
have to put a stop to it
vaccinations with russian-made sputnik v
have increased in recent weeks thanks to
government mandates and new restrictions
doubling to around three hundred
thousand a day but overall only around a
third of russians have gotten their
first shot of the rest some say they'd
rather wait for an international vaccine
but around half don't intend to get
vaccinated at all including many medical
personnel provoking growing frustration
among the country's medical community
people aren't behaving correctly
it's sad to see it
produced a great vaccine sputnik v
i have full confidence in sputnik
it's comparable to vaccines produced in
the west
why don't we use it i don't know
frustration is also spreading among many
in the service industry the branch was
especially hard hit by previous lockdown
measures and now they say they're paying
the price for russia's vaccine hesitancy
and preparing for a long winter
we're looking at how we're going to
survive the next lockdown i think
everything is going to be much harder
because everyone understands this is
just the beginning and it could go
beyond the 8th of november
but we're just going to have to deal
with it
as the delta variant continues to spread
government officials warn russia's
fourth wave is only likely to get worse
let's talk more about the situation in
russia with anton barczyk head of the
european university's institute of
interdisciplinary medical research in
saint petersburg welcome to dw anton
what is your explanation of many
russians vaccine hesitancy
yeah
hello and yeah
of course uh
unfortunately we knew about this problem
with vex inheritance before so it's not
something you just that pandemic has
highlighted highlighted this program uh
problem to you to everyone i know
but uh i think the issue is the lack of
this culture of vaccination in adult
population uh we do not have any other
population-based vaccination problems in
russia for
in adults so we have flu vaccine but
only part of population is accepting
that and we don't have uh national hpv
vaccination program
uh and yeah i think it's it's it's it's
goes beyond the pandemic so it's a it's
it's a problem with uh
vaccination well vaccination seems to be
the way out of the pandemic what
attempts are being made in russia to
combat this hesitancy who is promoting
the vaccination campaign and how
i think that one of the problems is a
lack of trust and the government of
course the state is promoting
vaccination but there's a lack of
um
there was a lack of convincing data
showing that the vaccination is
effective vaccination is safe
uh uh for example in many other
countries we we have seen
many publications uh which are related
to safety and effectiveness of the
vaccines in russia we have only
one publication uh launched publication
of sputnik v and uh
until
uh the last month we didn't have any
other available data on the vaccine
effectiveness and safety
that's one of the
problems this problem of lack of the
data lack of trust
now in some cases on vaccination is
already compulsory for certain job
groups such as shop assistants waiters
lecturers
does it help or does it only fuel the
resistance against vaccination when
there is hesitancy already in place
uh i i think it helps but
it doesn't help a lot so some people
also those uh
so-called
cavite
passports kind of uh quara cords which
are used in russia also
uh
helping a bit
we at the moment have a bit more um the
proportion of those who got at least one
uh
shot is a bit more than those who
plan to have it in the
in the beginning of pandemic that's
that's a good thing but still it's not
it's not i mean changing the global
situation
now you mentioned uh that people may be
lacking a
lack of trust when it comes to vaccine
if we talk about sputnik v the the
russian vaccine medical experts say it
is fine
russian experts say it is fine
international experts say it is also
close
to vaccines that are being produced in
the west
uh yes it is booting is fine and we we
got our independent uh data showing that
it's it's quite effective and
we have data from other countries from
san marino from argentina that it's safe
so it's fine but i think the
introduction the way it was introduced
it was a bit wrong so it was introduced
before any any data any results were
published and also we have two other
vaccines unfortunately they are not so
widespread
uh korevak and epivac corona and we do
not have any data on those vectors and
so although they were introduced already
and in
for population so i think that's also
kind of
uh the population they they were
a bit confused the way it was introduced
and they were like saying that it's 100
effective although
you know data were published
at that point yeah russian president
vladimir putin has called on the
military to build more medical
facilities for the rapidly growing
number of coveted 19 patients what
scenario do you expect in the coming
weeks
um one um
there's this vaccination and we need of
course we need to to uh increase the
uptake uh
the vaccine uptake but there's also uh
we have
at least in petersburg other big cities
we have a uh
quite
quite a
quite a
big proportion of population uh who had
cavite 19. so they have
immune defense
after the infection
so if we combine those with those who
took the vaccine and those who had
created an infection maybe we'll we are
near the kind of new herd immunity
threshold which is a bit um
like almost i think above 90 for delta
variant so we'll see what's going to
happen next but at least during this
wave
although
there are no measures nothing is
controlled right
the number of cases is not as high as
in summer or in winter right
epidemiologist antoine barczyk thank you
for your thoughts
thank you
russia's neighbor ukraine has an even
lower vaccination rate with only around
17 of the population fully vaccinated
that's one of the lowest in europe the
capital kiev is now taking steps to
change that by restricting access to
public transport and venues for people
who remain unvaccinated against covet
19. non-vaccinated residents will no
longer be able to go to work and visit
public places unless they have tested
negative restaurants hotels and fitness
centers will remain open only if all
employees are vaccinated or have
negative daily tests
now it's time for one of your questions
here's our science correspondent derek
williams
are there places where life has returned
to normal
i don't think that normal life is is
really a term that we should use anymore
because people say it when they want to
describe life before the pandemic and
and like everything in the past that's
never coming back um the world has moved
on hundreds of millions of people
have been infected with covet 19 and and
over 5 million people have died from it
so far but
but i bet there are places where the
coronavirus maybe
hasn't dominated the discourse
as heavily as it has here in europe
believe it or not according to the who
dashboard
there are around a dozen countries still
reporting
zero cases of the disease
but nearly all of them are small island
nations in the pacific
now i really have no idea how people
there feel but maybe they still live
lives
largely free of the fear of infection
to call that normal though is i think
probably a stretch because strict rules
on travel to keep out the disease i
would guess have likely devastated
livelihoods in places like that which
depend heavily on tourism in a few other
places where where the pandemic hit a
lot harder but authorities now seem to
have it at least somewhat under control
fears appear to have subsided somewhat
but but they aren't banished completely
here in europe for instance
most scandinavian countries dropped
nearly all of their domestic covert
restrictions
back in september
hoping that high levels of vaccination
had turned the tide
but as winter approaches
climbing numbers of infections there and
in other parts of the continent have
found doubts on whether at least some
measures
might have to be reintroduced so
long story short i'm guessing
that life hasn't really returned to to
normal anywhere but as i said at the
start
i think that's become a pretty relative
term
and before we go opposition to
coronavirus mandates has been growing in
parts of the u.s like in new york city
where vaccine mandate opponents held a
nighttime demonstration on staten island
the protest came after about 9 000 of
the city's 300 000 municipal workers
were put on unpaid leave for refusing to
comply with a new rule requiring them to
get vaccinated against covet 19.
thousands of city firefighters called in
sick in an apparent protest over the
requirement the mayor says
there have been no disruptions to city
services
that's our show thanks for watching
[Music]